version
very nice
very nice graphics
right
we try to
show
the nice landscape
of china
this is not the beginning
of the real game
they heard fiona
yellow turban rebellion that's a very
uh
famous event
i'm sure fans are already familiar with
three kingdoms
so i we try to
meet their
expectations i want to also ask you
about the actions i think many are
watching this for the first time
there they use different weapons in
martial arts
depends how they
fight against you you can change the way
you fight
and
so and you can
make them weaker
many
depends on the preference of the player
you can think about your own strategy
what's this flag
this is the flag for the army
control the area and you can also grow
with it so you are expanding your
territory correct
i talked about morale
by putting a flag out now i'm world
three
[Music]
on top of that tiger you see five
this shows
the
parameter for strength
when you're three the opponent is five
so
the opponent is stronger
correct
the sword is burning yes this is also
one of the
technique
we have actions with fire
this action is good for fire
right bottom
yes
this is kind of magic
or tactics
and utilizing it you can
be stronger or in a better position in
fighting
i was watching it
you are spreading out all the guts
we try to make sure that it's quick
and if you defeat
the enemy
you can get some equipment and you still
oh
but then you can get stronger
can you explain
is
but
you
want to
be more offensive or more supportive or
you can maintain good balance among five
players
or you can focus on
one area
or if you want to enhance one strength
that's okay too
you just defeat
enemies
yes you can get values as experienced
depends on the player's preference you
can allocate the points to the strength
when you are defeated you lose this
experience value
forever
is that a person
warrior
yes
he is one of the warrior from the yellow
turban rebellion
you got it and you lost hp
the green gauge is hp
and the gauge below that is for
spirit
so if
enemy is stronger you see orange
and if the gauge goes all the way then
you won't be able to do anything anymore
but then you can go back with deflect
and when you use tactics
the
value on the gauge goes down what is
this
shinjuku
divine beast
we by using it you
are in a better position now
the timing of deflect is quite
sensitive
yes the move mental force you have to
understand it
better
already mastered how to do it
so his play is quite smooth
but uh if you're a beginner it's
difficult but if you get used to playing
with it
so when the different success succeeds
and
then
the enemies
very nice actions
i'm surprised myself
i'm playing well today
the boss is different for the trial
version
so i wanted to show a different version
of boss
then you you're getting defeated
as you speak to us
it's more interesting now
please defeat the
defeat boss
can you
getting close
that was a nice move
[Music]
[Music]
and you are going to show something
new
first in tgs right yes
we are going to introduce the stage with
lubu i think you know him when you know
three kingdoms
yes it is available available for online
multiplayer so there are some moves you
can make
yes so it's kind of
chinese
moves and you can use these moves to
make a communication like bruce lee i
feel kung fu here
so
let's start the battle
oh it is
great and dark
so lugu is on red hair yes
you know
the
lulu is the best human being the red
hair is the best horse you know he is
the most powerful in the three kingdoms
and the life is less than half
you are supposed to be doing good today
right
but uh
so it's not really win or lose
i i want to do that deflect
when i
deflect the attack
we can take lubu down from red pair
but uh now i'm defeated
again
well
he can still fight he can still fight
we have we have some time
so it means that i get defeated
twice
three times or four times
well i want to
see that lugu's life gets halved
which one do you want to see like a test
play version
or the other version
maybe i can take a revenge
so let's do the battle against boo-boo
again
well i didn't say i'm going to defeat
him
a number of
uh crushing defeats the players
experienced in tgs now i want you to
show us
we can win
what lubu is the most powerful person
on the planet
well one attack is so powerful
yes
that lubu is the boss you will see in
the middle or toward the end of the game
so he is very strong
so
when you play and you cannot defeat the
boss you want to earn a lot of
experience points yes you can do that or
you can do the multiplayer
i was going to talk a lot
i i wanted to talk more
i used the one item to recover my life
but it didn't work so uh you know
you are dead again even sooner
you know
[Music]
has a great weapon and he is good at um
ball and arrow and he is with the red
hair and he's too strong
maybe we have the time for another
battle yes
one last battle
do you want to do it no no i don't want
to do it
we are not torturing torturing you so
why don't you play
i was not
expecting to
play against booboo well the longer you
show the game
and the uh the better the users
understand about the game so you are
doing a pr activity right now
yes
she is really agile
and
i want you to
take him down from red hair first
and i am reducing his spirit
and it's easy to say it but it's very
difficult to do it now he is on the
ground
[Music]
nice
maybe not no chance
no
again
crushing defeat
actually
four defeats
the record high during the live
streaming i'm embarrassed
so uh it's great game to play right
yes the players try and
i want all the players to beat lubu yes
please do the revenge for us
thank you it was a lot of information
the first information in tgs and we know
more about the game
and please look forward to more new
information
and that was the game play for war long
foreign